so
relax
[Music]
relax
relax your awareness
[Music]
relax your awareness
into the infinite perfection
there is no lack
there's no disharmony
the perfect expression
of infinity
relax your awareness
[Music]
if you feel a relaxation
in your awareness
more and more towards the infinite
perfection
that we are
then you're sinking in to our true
nature
and the more anxious
the more jittery
the less you're sinked in to the
infinite perfection
it's closer to you than your own
breath is the infinite perfection that
we are
it's so beautiful
it's majestic
everything radiating pure
infinite perfection
so
even your heartbeat in itself
is infinite perfection
gratitude for that infinite perfection
the more that you relax
into your awareness
relax
relax
relax into your
awareness
[Music]
the more you'll become sensitive
to the infinite perfection
our relationship with silence
is paramount
just be in
pure non-dual
silence
you already are the infinite perfection
yet it remains for you to recognize it
not intellectually
not philosophically
but experientially
recognize the subtlety
of the infinite perfection
recognize the eternity
recognize the illusion of time
time in itself
is the largest illusory anchor
of man's ignorance
let go relax
drop back into your awareness
relax
that is our most pure
nature infinite
perfection
so
increase your sensitivity
increase your subtlety
relax drop back
into your awareness
not the objects not the emotions
not the thoughts feelings or beliefs
but the pure bear empty
uncolored awareness
drop back in
pure infinite perfection
our nature is pure
infinite perfection
yet it remains for you to recognize it
relax
let go
back into your awareness
and the eternity of that
awareness
take the concept of time
and flush it down the toilet
it does not serve you
it anchors man to ignorance
of eternity and of infinity
and of his perfection
you are not the finite biological
creature that the matrix
subscriptions have made you out to be
you are absolute infinite
perfection that
is your nature
relax your awareness
that is key silence
is key
relax your awareness and be silent
the diamond of infinite perfection
is already around your neck
yet it remains for you to recognize it
what we are looking for
is what is looking
that is infinite perfection
relax into that infinite perfection
and make that home
make it home
make bliss and peace
and perfection your
home
that is your nature
yet it remains for you to recognize it
[Applause]
uh
thank you
uh